[Music]
hello boys and girls ladies and germs
this is tim ferriss and welcome to
another episode of the tim ferriss show
where it is my job to interview
world-class performers from all
different fields all different stripes
to tease out the frameworks the habits
routines favorite books all the goodies
that you can apply test in your own
lives my guest today i'm very excited
about diana chapman
c-h-a-p-m-a and diana is a co-founder of
the conscious leadership group and a
co-author of the book the 15 commitments
of conscious leadership which i am
rereading right now it just so happens
her passion is to help organizational
leaders and their teams eliminate drama
in the workplace and beyond she's worked
with more than 1 000 ceos and is a
well-respected facilitator for the young
president's organization ypo working
with their forums and chapters worldwide
she's been a speaker at tedx
mindful leadership summit wisdom 2.0
stanford graduate school of business and
many more when diana is not with her
clients she can often be found gardening
at her suburban homestead in the santa
cruz mountains of california sounds nice
doesn't it she lives there with her
husband of more than 30 years you can
find her online at conscious.is
on twitter the handle is at conscious lg
facebook conscious leadership group and
on youtube conscious is
now and there are so many different
directions i could go but first diana
welcome to the show so nice to see you
oh thank you so much i'm really happy to
be here
so i thought i would
just establish some bonafides right off
the bat and then we're gonna do a little
chronological shuffling so first i want
to read a quote from
the team portion of the website so under
your name at conscious.i
s
there's a quote
from dustin moskovitz now for those who
don't know who dustin is dustin is
co-founder of asana prior to that he was
co-founder of facebook in 2011
he was at least at the time the youngest
self-made billionaire
in the history
of the planet as far as i know and
here's the quote quote working with
diana has dramatically changed the way i
react to challenges and stress in my
life preserving my energy to direct
towards more constructive pursuits as a
coach she has a gift for guiding me
through introspection on the stories i
create about events and people in a
structured way that inevitably leads to
perspective shifts we can't control the
fact that bad things are going to happen
but how we react to those events is what
really matters
and that we can learn to control
when we have the right attitude and
resourcing adversity becomes strictly an
opportunity to learn and grow okay so
this is the kind of quote that a lot of
folks would would kill for maybe die for
certainly amputate a few fingers for
now i before we
dig into all sorts of juicy bits that we
could pull out of that quote as a
jumping off point i want to go back to
1997. so i
did not expect to find this i didn't
expect to find anything in particular
but this is what i found this is on
kritio.com
in 1997 diana chapman was a stay-at-home
mom teaching scrapbooking in ann arbor
michigan quote as mainstream alive as
they come end quote she says
uh i didn't know any of this so number
one you can't believe everything you
read on the internet so is this true
and then assuming some aspect of it is
true could you
tell us about the gift from your
brother-in-law around that time
yeah so it is true i was the
quintessential stay-at-home mom
all things
being with my kids being part of the
school you know head of the pta all that
good stuff
and i
was though very interested in personal
development spirituality human
consciousness that was always in the
background
but i
was very devoted to my children i was
teaching scrapbooking to other moms i
mean i was so cute i was really cute
and my brother-in-law
was a top ceo in the country and he was
very very devoted to personal
development
and he was a connoisseur of finding
great coaches
and i think the truth was that he and my
sister-in-law were concerned about my
marriage
and wondered if we were going to make it
and so
they recommended that we go out to
california and take a training with gay
and kathlyn hendricks of the hendrix
institute
actually they gave us five grand he said
you can do whatever you want with the
money but i'm going to recommend you go
out to california so i joyfully could
not wait to go
i didn't know anything about them but he
said you know they're the best so off we
went and it was a profoundly
life-changing week and i thought to
myself
why am i just learning these tools
and i'm gonna devote the rest of my life
making sure people get access to them
and that's what i've done
what did you feel
or experience or what changes did you
observe that led you to have such a
strong
reaction
first of all i learned about this thing
called the drama triangle
and which many people out there may have
heard about but i realized my whole life
is running around on this drama triangle
and the drama triangle was created by
stephen cartman back in the 70s and he
defined ways in which human beings get
caught in victimhood
that
create reactivity and i realized i'm on
the triangle most of the time and and
there is a big cost to me and my people
when i'm on the drama triangle and so
that was the wake up call for me and
then i just spent every day since
looking for all the tools i can for how
to keep myself out of that triangle as
much as possible
since you mentioned it let's just jump
right into
the drama triangle could you
give us an overview of what it is and
how you might use it
okay so cartman says
many of us got trained to live in a
state of victimhood and there are three
unique flavors of victimhood in the
drama triangle we call them bases
so the first base is the pure victim and
the pure victim you know it's so hard
here i'm trying i don't know it's just
any kind of a
oh help you know it's got this very
disempowered feeling and it's somehow
like they've got the power somebody else
has it not me and i'm very at the effect
of things so i could be at the effect of
my bank account at the effective this
email that just came in at the effect of
the traffic at the effect of the new
policy on going back to work at the
effect of covid all those things are
forms of being a victim
then the next role in the drama triangle
is the villain and the villain's job is
to blame
so i can blame me god i should have
known that or i should have been more
prepared or any should have over here on
me or i'm not smart enough or i can't
count on myself that's all villaining
toward myself or we can villain toward
another you know you you're the reason
why i'm not having as much fun as i
could be having or we could be a villain
to a group of people which is very
popular in our culture so we all know
who's screwing it up for the rest of us
you know it's that group over there and
everybody's pointing to particular
groups who are the bad guys
so villain's very popular because it
gets our adrenaline really kicking in i
think it's actually in the terms of
service on twitter that you have to play
that role when you use the service
anyways it's a side note
right right who's who's who's screwing
it up who's wrong yeah you don't know
you're wrong i'm right and then the last
role in the drama triangle is the hero
it's also called the reliever or the
rescuer and the hero's job is to seek
temporary relief
so
oh my god i had such a hard day today at
work let me call home i'm gonna drink my
alcohol or go might do my gaming or get
lost in netflix or whatever i'm gonna do
to give myself some temporary relief and
it works but i gotta do it again
tomorrow because tomorrow i'm gonna come
home potentially burn out again and then
i'm gonna have to do the same pattern so
heroin
is temporary relief over and over again
so i can hero myself i could hear
another you know oh you look like you're
struggling at work and um let me take
over some of your work that you're doing
and i might do that i could do that from
a place of real presence but when i'm a
hero doing it i'm actually creating some
codependence where i keep needing you to
not be able to handle your work so i can
keep helping and then i'll resent you
over time
and then we can hear them you know
there's lots of philanthropies
especially in the past they're getting
better at this now where we just throw a
bunch of money at a population and then
next year they have all the same issues
and they need more money and nothing
ever really changes
so
the key thing is temporary relief so we
all know the story about you can give
the man a fish every night or you could
teach him to fish for himself so the
hero gives the man the fish night after
night after night and if you're off the
drama triangle you shift to a place
where you see people as empowered and
the hero asks good questions to help
people get more effective around them
so
my next question i want to
share an observation
from my rereading of the book
and then the next question just to plant
the seed is i'm going to ask you why
it's called the drama triangle what
drama actually means here
but in my reread which i'm in the middle
of right now of the 15 commitments of
conscious leadership which was
recommended to me by dustin
and i think it was also recommended in
my last book and tribe of mentors by
dustin and
there's a section that i needed to
reread which was
related to the drama triangle and it
pointed out that
the villain
could take the form of someone in a
meeting
who to try to resolve conflict or maybe
not resolve to try to
minimize conflict always takes the blame
like eventually at the end of the
meeting they just say you know what it's
my fault i should have done this this
this this and this
and it's easy at least for me to
conflate
radical responsibility
with
overly blaming myself for everything and
i i don't actually
have a great way to approach navigating
discerning those two for me if that
makes any sense yeah so so we could we
could try to unpack that or we could
jump to why it's called the drama
triangle but i'll let you choose the
direction well let me do both so the
reason why it's called the drama
triangle is because the whole triangle
is set up for a ne
you know it's i'm right you're wrong
you're to blame or i'm to blame it's
it's not asking everybody to really take
a hundred percent responsibility for how
they're co-creating experiences
so if i'm in the drama triangle the
villain if i'm taking on
i'm more responsible what happens is
i'll say oh i'm here at the meeting you
guys and look it's my fault i'll take
some of your responsibility and take it
all on me
and so
there is a place to say hey i have a
part in how i've co-created this let me
tell you my part
that would be me taking my hundred
percent and then i would also know that
everybody else has a part to play too
so i'm not taking on their
responsibility as well that's the
difference between
a villain and somebody who's who's just
simply acknowledging i have a role to
play here
goddess
thank you
so we were chatting before we started
recording
and
you and i have spoken quite a few times
before we've met before spent time
together and you asked me why
i invited you on to the podcast and
there were a number of answers i gave
one of them was related to kinesthetic
awareness or would our mutual friend and
your
business partner jim detmer
have called at least in his notes to me
for this conversation
this may be your turn for all i know bq
so like iq eq but body intelligence
and i feel like you're very
well calibrated for this and when we
spoke
maybe a year and a half ago two years
ago i was working on this this no book
you might recall and then as i kept
working on it and kept working on it i
kept coming up with great reasons to say
no to the entire book which was uh very
meta and i ended up stopping but we
spoke a lot about
the
whole body yes
and
i would love to maybe use that as a
wedge
to start the conversation because i
found this so incredibly helpful
when i am certainly prone to over
intellectualizing everything into some
extremely complicated matrix or
spreadsheet or god knows what so
uh could you lead us into that in
whatever way makes sense
sure
the idea is that we have these different
centers of intelligence so we have our
head our heart our gut
and iq eq bq are
some of the ways we might be describing
those things these days so body
intelligence is
a recognition that i have an instinctual
awareness
that
is
known by my sensations
known by how the body feels
and that there's a lot actually there
that if we start to drop into the body
and pay attention
it's it's got a lot of guidance for us
as does our emotions as does our
intellect
and so
i do have a ton of access to my body
intelligence i think it's what i lead
with in my own
having getting clarity about which
directions to go in my life
and and i put a lot of attention on it
so it's very palpable to me my body
screams often you know no don't do that
even though my intellect might have an
understanding of why
so let's if you wouldn't mind walk
people through how they might understand
and use the whole body yes
because for me
when something is screaming
i'm
decent at paying attention right but
it's not always a scream right
oftentimes it is a little more nuanced
so could you walk people through
the whole body yes and what
the sort of
flight checklist looks like
yeah well i could
have people if we wanted to go through
an experience of starting to feel what
their whole body yes and nose feels like
great yeah let's do that should we do
that it's very experiential so it'll
take about 10 minutes and i'll have
people they're listening i'd recommend
they close their eyes
wonderful
all the time in the world this isn't uh
morning television okay so the idea is
that your body knows when there's a no
when there's a yes and when there's a
what i'm going to call a subtle no
and we say anything other than a whole
body yes is a no and to your point it's
easy to hear those screaming no's but
not so easy to hear the subtle no for
example
someone contacted our organization the
other day and he wanted to
talk
and it wasn't clear to me whether he was
trying to sell us something or whether
he genuinely had clients that he wanted
to connect us with
and even in my
i had suspicions that it wasn't as
clean as he was suggesting and i asked
for clarification and his clarification
still
i couldn't really tell
but
my body didn't know
i felt this flat feeling in my body when
i thought about having the call and
unfortunately my head said well maybe
you're not sure so let's have the call
and indeed it was a sales call and it
was not a good use of my time and i
quickly hung up but i that was a time in
which i skipped over my no because it
was very subtle and my intellect started
to get worried like what if i'm missing
something and you know what if you don't
know
so
i use this all the time and i'm still
learning as i did just last week
to
pay attention to the intelligences that
are outside of just my intellect and so
for you all if you want to learn more
about this
what i'd like you to do is close your
eyes
and i'd like you to bring to mind an
experience from the past that was deeply
valuable to you
it was something that was nurturing it
was something you would gratefully
repeat that scene again
it could be
a time when you were celebrated it could
be a time when you were in a highly
creative state that made something
valuable
it could be a time when you were in
nature feeling deeply centered
so i'd like you to go back into that
scene as best you can and
see the images of that scene
and hear the sounds
and as you're in that scene
i want you to start to pay attention to
the body
and see if you can notice
just simply
how the body is vibrating right now
when you imagine yourself
in that scene
seeing those images
hearing the sounds
how does your body vibrate
is there a particular direction in which
energy is flowing through the body
now some of you might go diane i'm not
feeling anything here that's fine
just imagine if you were feeling
something
that'd be okay that it might feel like
pretend just for now
is there a certain temperature
that you notice in the body
for some people they might feel very
specific sensations
it might feel like shapes inside the
body
some people might be auditory and hear
tones
or see visuals in their mind's eye
what you're doing here is getting a map
of what does a whole body yes feel like
i'm just strolling around inside of the
body feeling what you're feeling
no right or wrong answers here and
everybody is so unique we all have our
own different ways we feel it
for me my body gets warm
there's a uprising of energy it flows up
for me
a push there's a push in the flow for me
but yours will be what it is
and so then i'd like you to take one
last
like a memory take a memory shot of this
so you can remember what this feels like
then i'd like you to shake it off and
let it go
and then i want you to think of a scene
in the past that you don't want to
repeat
and i don't recommend finding something
traumatizing find something that you
really didn't feel like was a good use
of your time didn't serve you you don't
want to repeat it ever again
or you prefer not to
if you can bring that image to mind
and again
see the visuals of that memory and hear
the sounds
and i want you to notice what happens
now in the body
is there a different
way the body's vibrating
how is the direction of energy flowing
or not flowing in this
version
is there a difference in temperature
any other significant sensations or
shapes you feel in there on the body
and again tones
in the ears or visuals in your mind's
eye may also be included
and you're getting a map for what no
this is a big no
i don't want i don't want this
i don't think this is going to serve me
just mapping the territory in the body
for what does this feel like
and take one last picture of that
and shake that one off
and then we've got one more to do and
this is the subtle note this is similar
to what i was just describing earlier of
taking a meeting
you know it didn't kill me to take the
meeting it didn't hurt i
lasted 10 minutes and i got off the
phone but it wasn't a yes it wasn't an
alive experience for me
so this is called a subtle no so i want
you to think back everybody's got in the
last two to four weeks
something that's happened in which it
was a
wasn't bad wasn't good
see if you can come back and
see that scene in your mind's eye
and hear those sounds
and you're going to check and see what's
a subtle note feel like for you
how do you experience
that scene what do you notice in the
body
how does it vibrate here
how does energy flow
or not flow
is there a difference in temperature
what parts of the body light up
sensations
and tones or visuals as well
trying on here and again if you don't
notice much that's okay just imagine if
you did notice what would you notice
and this is your map for what a subtle
no feels like
and you want to remember this feeling so
the next time somebody says hey you want
to go out to lunch or could you meet me
to talk about abc that you if you feel
this likely it's an invitation for you
to try no
so you can shake that one off and then
we'll
bring our attention back
to the ongoing conversation
how is that for you tim
it's a great exercise it's been a long
time since i've done an inventory like
that and
i took some notes and i'll share a few
things just in case this
helps other people i noticed that all
three had different breathing patterns
the breathing
was a very different
cadence and feeling
nice so that seemed to be of a very
clear
variable
across the three
and just give an example of the clear
note the the strong no was
frontal head tension
chest tightness feeling hot
none of which exists in the yes state
right as an example
and then
i thought of this subtle no which i i
don't think i've spent much time on
before which is hilarious because of
course it's probably where i need to
spend the most time is assessing that
and i thought of this experience
recently
it was the first example that came to
mind because
i really try not to
say yes to things but sometimes you say
yes to things that seem like a yes and
then you get into the experience and
it's not a yes
the bill of lading was deceptive
and i ended up at this dinner that was
kind of play fancy i didn't expect it to
be play fancy but it was an expensive
dinner and it just was not
enjoyable the food wasn't great and i
didn't want to be there
and i was thinking of this experience
and
i noticed that
in contrast to the strong yes and the
strong no both of which have a certain
degree of focus
i in the subtle know have a very i wrote
down shifty energy and
fidgety just like feeling unsettled
and
that then i suppose becomes your
sort of landmark right off in the
distance where you can orient
yourself with respect to decision making
or continuing or not continuing with
something so i found this very
helpful and i should also just mention
that this has historically been
a what would we call it a
development opportunity
aka weakness
growth opportunity slash massive
achilles heel
this body awareness i think that we
could we could spend a lot of time on it
we don't need to but just i learned to
dissociate very effectively really early
on in my life for a lot of reasons and
so it's getting reacquainted with
feeling yeah has been a long process
and
thank you for that i found that very
helpful
and and could you help us connect this
to how people would
use this
inventory
so i'd recommend starting out using it
in really simple ways
so start with
looking at a menu
and as you're looking at the menu just
notice like does that fidgety come in
when you look at the sandwich you know
versus the sandwich and see if you can
start to see what yes feels like or
you're driving back home and you've got
a couple of different routes to take
home
you know try on okay i'm going to go
this way and notice what happens in the
body versus i go this way make this a
practice for things that don't have a
lot of meaning that you know it's not a
big deal
you can also do it with time let's say
you're thinking about gathering up with
a group of friends and they say what
time try on like okay well what if we
met at five and just notice what happens
in the body when i try five and then 5
30 and 6 and 6 30 and just see if you've
got like a place where your body starts
to hum like oh wow 6 30 that's where it
really hit and then
let's choose 6 30. so that's a way to do
it and then what you'll notice is at
least for me i really liked the results
i kept creating in these
simpler options and then i just kept
using it more and more
with more important decisions and then
now
you know the biggest decisions are this
is something i choose regularly i i've
learned to trust it so that
you know i had a
client who i thought was in trouble in
another country and
i contacted the family and said i think
you need to go help this person and you
know they're like you want us to leave
and go
go check on this family member
and i said
my body was shaking with
clarity about it my head was like i i
don't know i'm not i couldn't tell you
for sure but my body knew
and
they they went and it turned out it was
a really could have been a life-saving
moment that they went and
intellectually i had some data but my
body was the one that really guided me
to be aggressive in getting that
person's support
yeah this this has been
really impactful for me and
it seems so
simple and on some levels
it is but i mean very often it's the
simple valuable things that we
neglect perhaps because we think they
are simplistic but that's not the same
thing
and
i think that it's
common also for people who are very
ahead
intellect-focused who've been rewarded
for that
to
just end up being a hammer looking for
nails basically and
i had a lot of trouble identifying what
yes felt like and i still do if i'm
being honest so uh i mean there are
times when it's super obvious when i'm
just like the the yes in all caps and
like marquee lights and neon yes okay
fine then i
i when it bashes me over the head with
like awesomeness i know what that feels
like
but if it's in some cases a meeting or
an investment or a person or a dinner
with certain people
it's hard for me to identify what a full
body yes
feels like but i know what it doesn't
feel like if i go from like head to
chest to gut if there's any tension
in one of those three it's a no good
then then i would say your yes is a void
of those sensations
right so let that be what it is let
yourself go that is a whole body yes my
whole body yes is a void of those no
sensations
and that's enough don't you don't need
to make it any more than that
yeah
yeah that's true and it makes sense to
me that you might not have the whole
light up you know some people do have
this zing you know that they feel as a
yes but some people don't and so yeah
just trust your own version of it so
you'll just know oh my yes is
it just is without the reactive patterns
i notice in my body when the no is here
well let's let's use that as a segue
and the fact that i i don't have the
zing i'm not sure that the fact i don't
have this
zing and i do have it when it's again
sort of an avalanche of
sort of spectacular goodness but
otherwise
my yes response can be very muted i i do
think that i have trained myself
sometimes in the name of stoicism i
think often in the
hope to protect myself from
disappointment to not celebrate and i do
think that premature celebration of huge
business deals and stuff can
bite you in the ass and that it's a good
idea to temper expectations at the same
time there's a cost
there's a very real cost to training
yourself not to celebrate
and one of the notes that jim
as in jim detmer for people who are
listening sent to me i asked him what
your superpowers were and he gave me a
number of them and one was
play as a way to live life increase
learnings deepen relationships and lead
organizations diana is the best of
anyone i have ever met at living a life
of play and inviting others to play
along so for those who don't know jim
jim
would not say something like this
lightly
so
could you please this is this is
something that i want to cultivate in
myself and i'm i really am not sure of
how to go about it so i would love
to explore this and you can take that
anywhere you would like
okay
well
when you were talking earlier about not
sure you know about that yes you think
maybe you'd like to have more of that
one thing i would say is
i think yeses are about igniting our
creative energy and our creative energy
is very connected to our sexual energy
and so
for me a lot of yes yes feels very
sexual
i feel turned on
and so i think there are a lot of people
who
put that away
for good reasons along the way
and so one of the things that i think is
important is for people to start coming
back and tuning back into letting
themselves be a sexual being
letting themselves have sensations
that feel
igniting and
and that doesn't have to mean that you
you know want to go have sex or do
they're very different things i know a
lot of people have been sex without
sexual feelings so they're they're
separate but there's a i want to invite
people to feel how good you can feel in
the body
how do you do that i know that sounds
silly but it's like how do you
foster slash
allow that right because i'm not i'm not
consciously i don't have any catholic
guilt or anything that leads me to
consciously throttle that right there i
don't have a voice in my head that says
that's
not okay i feel like it's more
if it exists in me it's more
subconscious
well just in general because
just see if you can find one place in
the body that feels pleasurable it
doesn't have to necessarily be named
sexual but just where is the pleasure in
the body
and it could just be a tiny little spot
or you could feel something like for me
right now there's like a tickle in my
chest
i feel some um
bubbly
champagne bubbles coming up through my
spine
feels like it's coming up through
floating out of the top of my head
i feel some
warmth in my feet it's pleasurable
and so it's just starting to put your
attention on pleasure itself
and then keep attending to it you know
keep giving your attention to it and
then it often keeps it starts spreading
around and then all of a sudden there's
this really wonderful like woo hoo
quality that's happening in the body and
then for me that's
part of then what ignites the play
because it's just there's so much
aliveness joy
creative
possibilities and then it's like okay
what are we gonna do with this and then
how much fun could we have and
that's that's just sort of the
water i swim in
has it always
been that way is this
diana out of the box or is it something
that either you've you've trained more
in yourself or that you've seen people
train effectively right in terms of
turning the tide because i'm sure you
have a lot of clients i have to imagine
who are doing therapy coaching
medicine work etc and they're like god i
just need more play i just need more
playing it's like okay well now what
right
well i might say let's play with the
fact that you need more play like can we
make that bigger oh i need more play oh
god you're like i i tend to say let's
exaggerate everything because that's one
of the easiest quickest forms of play is
exaggerate where you're at
so make wherever you're at bigger and so
if it's like i can't play it's so hard
for me to play i go okay well let's play
with that make that bigger until all of
a sudden now you're kind of giggling
because it seems funny
and then you just played
so exaggeration is one of my favorite
ways so when it when i am coaching
people and they're in some place that
they say they don't want to be and i say
well then let's make it bigger wherever
you're at and then it always pops them
through
i like that
loving pressure let's talk about loving
pressure that was a term that jim sent
over
bringing loving pressure to
relationships she's a genius at bringing
the right balance of pressure kick you
in parentheses kick you in the ass and
love in parentheses support
understanding empathy
and as a result she's a black belt and
practicing candor so this is something
that has always struck me in our
interactions
and
this is not going to be a perfect segue
but i have to bring this up because who
knows if what i wrote for the notebook
will ever see the light of day i hope it
will maybe in a blog post or an article
at some point but could you please
could you please describe the voice
mail message that you had some years ago
do you know the one i'm talking about
yeah
yeah it was something like um
hi you've reached diana i may or may not
respond to this call and i'm gonna just
listen to
you know if i feel called i will and if
i don't i won't and
it was
it was uh
you know just very much of uh i'm gonna
listen in and decide to rather i'll call
you back and when i'll call you back and
so it was just basically saying don't
have any expectations
so your
your candor has has has really
jumped out as this sort of defining
characteristic of diana for me
so that's sort of the end of this bullet
that's in front of me but
how should people think of
loving
pressure
because i find myself flip-flopping
often
between two polar extremes this is
especially noticeable in my
intimate relationships where
either i'm like the hard-ass
like olympic
coach
i'm kind of like
the coach in the disney movie miracle if
anyone's seen that in ice hockey
or
i am from my perspective extremely
permissive and
overly supportive to the point of
subjugating my own feelings
it's not entirely dishonest but i'm kind
of dis a vowing part of me to be really
really
supportive
and this is especially true
with my girlfriend where there are times
to
i've learned i think this is important
there are times for me to
listen to listen for her to feel heard
and then there are times for me to
listen
to help with problem solving and it's
very good for me to clarify which she
wants in advance
but how do you think about
loving pressure and bringing that to
relationships
well again i think in order to do that
well you have to be connected to your
head your heart and your gut
that's certainly been
really clear to me that i have to be
fully present to know then what's the
balance of challenge and nurturing
so for example i had a guy who called me
recently was wanting to know if we could
work together and he was very very
depressed
and
i was asking him questions and he was
really stuck and he had a lot of
critical thoughts about himself
and he couldn't get motivated to do
anything and um
i said
you know i asked him about therapy he
said yeah i've been in therapy for a
year and i said okay you need to fire
your therapist
because you've got a lot of stories in
your head that you're believing and um
nobody's challenging you and the guy
stood up like he sat up really straight
and i felt him like pop out of some haze
he was in like the challenger so
woke something in him and so my you know
story i always make up about that guy is
he was just getting so nurtured but
nobody was bringing the challenge that
could help him break out of this state
he was in
and so
you know i just
knew that because and i and i was
thoughtful of from my own presence here
of what do i need to say to this guy
that he can hear i care about him but i
also say cut it out because where you're
how you're organizing yourself here
isn't going to take you to this new
place you want to go and he was really
grateful uh and he said thank you i i
really hear you that i need to i need to
question these beliefs i'm holding
so
that's my practice over and over again
is being able to listen to my body i was
with another conversation of the day and
people were talking about their opinions
about
the world and i just said hey i noticed
i'm contracting my body's contracting as
i hear you guys talking
that's all i had to say it was just i'm
just going to report what's happening
over here and it was a form of challenge
to them
and they went wow you know you're right
we're really in some fear-based thinking
here
so
my body helps just sometimes i just
report i notice i'm bored or i notice
i'm
withdrawing or i notice i'm getting
confused or i notice i'm contracting
those are ways i might just express a
little
pressure by just revealing what's here
and not making it mean anything but just
saying here's what's happening maybe
this is about you know something i don't
know about yet but let me just tell you
what's happening i don't think we do
that enough with each other
so let me ask a question about that
example so there are some folks talking
about
whatever they were talking about
and
some kind of fear-based
or what they recognized as fear-based
thinking in conversation and you say i'm
noticing that i'm feeling contracted
i just want to let you guys know
and they responded constructively these
are people i know well and we know we
play a similar game you've agreed to
this type of interaction yes they would
not i would not do this with just
anybody okay
okay so what would you do if if you're
in a mixed group or with people who
have not
agreed or made the commitments right and
uh we could talk more about the 15
commitments and commitments in general
but is there a way that you can give
voice to that with people who perhaps
don't have
the same playbook in front of them sure
i might say something like so what i
hear is you you want to be you know you
you believe you're right that xyz is
occurring
and that could be true
and i'm just wondering if you're open to
another
possibility that maybe it's not as true
as you think so i might just gently
bring a little challenger of asking them
to consider that there might be another
option
that's another form of how we challenge
each other
is questioning the stories we tell
because we're all just telling stories
all the time
or i might say
oh i
hadn't considered that perspective
i've been holding this perspective and i
might share my perspective and it just
depends on how well or not well i know
the crowd that would have me be more
thoughtful in how i might respond
when you're working with a client and
i'm coming back to the initial
quote that i read
from from dustin
so she has a gift as a coach she meaning
you as a gift for guiding me through
introspection on the stories i create
about events and people in a structured
way that inevitably leads to perspective
shifts
could you
walk us through how you might do that
with someone for instance this guy was
depressed and he says you know what
you're right my therapist sucks i'm
being handled with kid gloves but that's
making me remain a kid yeah so
i could use like a
you know occasional slap in the face
from
someone who's who's very supportive and
challenging and you say okay great
so from that point then what do you do
with those stories in this person i'm a
huge fan of byron katie and
i really love her work
and i do the work with myself and i do
the work with my clients and i say okay
is it true
is it true this thing you believe can
you absolutely know it's true
and you know i'm wise enough now to know
i can't absolutely know anything
and then
what's it like when you do really
believe you're right and
i help people find there's always some
suffering and then what would it be like
if you just couldn't believe it
and people find oh that's nice
it feels good and then okay great could
we just go look at the opposite you can
keep your righteous stories but can we
also ask you to hold the opposites as at
least is true so that the mind can get
to neutral and then
something else gets to happen and you're
doing that with turnarounds of various
types all the time i'm constantly asking
clients to turn around let's pick a
hypothetical or real example just so
people people can get a flavor of this
so byron katie
the work
i also have found really
really helpful in a number of cases
and
she's an unusual
unusual and powerful woman
to put it mildly so
so there are times when people will
interact and i remember meeting her for
the first time and i was like i don't
know if i can do what she does
but
when you actually work with the
worksheets and people can find this
online a lot of resources are available
for free online from byron katie
could you walk through say
a belief which i think she defines as a
thought we take to be true or something
along those lines
an example of a belief and then what
how you would do turnarounds on that
belief
and walk somebody through that well
let's see if we can find something real
for you if you're willing to like see if
we can find something that's irritated
you
maybe somebody did something that bugged
you or you're upset about some policy
out in the world or it's any place where
you notice you get a little triggered
[Music]
it's more of a like a paradox of choice
issue
than anything else for me let me see
if not i can find one
i always have judgments so i can find
something over here well i'll tell you
this is i
my relationship well we'll we'll
actually use one that relates to the
client you mentioned so i have had
extended depressive episodes
the majority of my life and so i have a
lot of fear around slipping into
depressive episodes and have viewed that
whether it's now whether it's a week
from now whether it's a year whether
it's five years from now as inevitable
okay right and scary and dangerous
so let's use that somehow okay and it
sounds like the judgment bite might be
something like i shouldn't slip into
depression or depressive episodes is
that right
yeah exactly i shouldn't it's dangerous
etc okay so which one is it is i
shouldn't or is it dangerous because it
sounds like that one kind of lit up for
you it's dangerous if i go into a
depressive episode yeah i think yeah
that's sure is that it that is okay it's
dangerous if you go into a depressive
episode is that true
so i always struggle with the first two
the first two questions
the other ones i have an easier time
with is it true i think it's true yes i
mean most the time when i have my
judgments i do think they're true in the
beginning but then i go okay tim
can you really truly i mean absolutely
no it's true like you'd put your life on
the line that if you have a depressive
that it's dangerous if you go into a
depressive episode
well you know it's kind of
tragically comic that you would use that
phrasing so here's what i can say i know
i i can say for sure that it has been
dangerous because i almost killed myself
in college
does that automatically mean that i will
be
at the precipice in that same way in the
future no
i can't say that with 100 certainty
yes you can't say that with 100
certainty so we're just trying to get to
i can't know for sure i mean i didn't
kill myself in the end where you're here
right right and we don't know if you
would want to kill yourself in the
in the future so we're just going i
can't absolutely know for sure it's true
so the first question is is it true
second question is can i absolutely know
for sure that it's true
you're saying no third question is
what's it like when you do believe that
thought so when you sit here and go whoa
it's going to be dangerous if i have a
depressive episode what's it like for
you when you believe that to be true
it's terrifying it's awful and any time
i feel even
a twinkling of
a possibility that i might be slipping
into a melancholy state i went to a jazz
performance recently and they were
playing very minor key music
and
i felt myself getting very uncomfortable
and actually that was the example i used
in my own mind when we were
is the second example that came to my
mind when i was thinking of
the whole body know recently even though
there were aspects of the performance i
really enjoyed but
as soon as i started feeling myself slip
into a sad what i would call depressive
state
there was a level of panic
sure
so that's who i am yeah when i believe
that to be true i'm a hyper vigilant and
panic-prone yeah makes sense i mean i i
feel it right now if i believe the story
that if i get into a depressive state
it's going to be dangerous i feel
panicky i can feel that hyper vigilance
i can feel like ah like really anxious
yeah yeah for sure so that's your
experience so let's just imagine that i
have this super power and your brain is
a computer
and
that thought
it's dangerous
to go into a depressive state is
actually like a computer program and i
have the ability to delete that program
out of the computer of your brain
it's gone so right now
i just did it it's gone so we're just
gonna pretend for a couple of minutes
here
and if you just couldn't believe that
anymore
what's it like
i think i would have
uh
almost certainly would have much more
calm
much more
presence right i wouldn't be future
tripping and
stuck in anxiety
i would
be much more joyful
i would have more space for other people
because i wouldn't be stuck on the me me
show yeah
yeah and i like to even get it get
yourself even more present like sit here
and sometimes i even encourage people to
close their eyes
but let yourself drop in right here in
this conversation
and you're now a man sitting here who
can't find that thought
it's a little more meditative this way
using your breath to keep opening what's
it like to be here
to be you
to be in this moment without the thought
there's no thought that's replaced it
you're just here without that one
uh relaxed
optimistic
energized
yeah
yeah and my experience is the more i
drop in the more i get to experience
more
states of presence
that if i especially like when you go
into that relaxed you could even drop in
even a little more and it keeps opening
up and these states can keep opening to
more and more
states of well-being
could i do a quick sidebar yeah
question which is
so i think a lot of people listening and
even me right now
i'm starting to get a little secondary
anxiety
by telling myself the story well wait a
second
if it is actually dangerous
i don't want to just go into a place of
denial where
good i take off my seat belt while i'm
driving at 80 miles an hour psychically
that sounds like a bad idea right so but
i don't want you to stop thinking i
suppose i just wanted to
get your reiteration that this is a
this is not the objective is not to
invalidate the belief the objective is
to do an exercise
embracing other alternatives and the
objective is to understand that at the
moment at least a depressive state isn't
what's creating the anxiety for you it's
the belief that it's going to be
dangerous that creates the anxiety right
that's what we're going after here is
we're going after the recognition
that your depressive state we actually
don't know how you will or will not be
but right now the danger you're creating
is in your own head by believing you're
right about your story
and so we're helping you question that
so that you can now
be aware and present for the possibility
that you might be going into a
depressive state in the future and how
can you do your best to
mitigate that
ride it if you do have it happen so that
you're not at the effect of it
[Music]
thank you all right so what's the next
step so then the next step is we don't
want you to get rid of it could be
dangerous because
i don't know maybe it could but we want
to help you come back to
recognizing that the opposite is at
least as true that it doesn't have to be
dangerous
so we're going to have you go
it's not dangerous going into a
depressive state is at least is true
can you give me a real example one that
not just your head but your heart and
your body like there's something that
your whole system goes ah
okay i can see how it's true that it
doesn't have to be dangerous if i go
into a depressive state can you give me
real evidence of how that could be at
least is true
uh
so doing i'm doing two things here i'm
i'm doing the exercise with you and i'm
also sort of providing an overlay for
people listening so we're just
and please correct me if i'm getting
into this wrong but what we're doing is
we're taking
the belief as a statement and we're
starting to play
with
that sentence and the words in that
sentence and how it's constructed right
i mean obviously specifically going
after the judgment so that your mind
judges it's going to be dangerous if i
go into a depressive state it's going to
be dangerous i'm right about how
dangerous it's going to be so we just
want to go can we just look at how the
opposite is true is it's not going to be
dangerous if you go into a depressive
state
so now we're coming up with evidence for
how is that at least how is that
statement it won't be
dangerous
at least as true
so i'll start with the kind of present
tense that it isn't dangerous because
that it won't be dangerous it's harder
for me but i will say
the fact of the matter is i'm here right
and i've had dozens of depressive
episodes yeah and i'm still here so
if
if the danger is suicide at least
to this point
it's
abundantly clear that that has not
happened so
yeah and i want you to really get that
not just in your head but i want you to
get that in your heart and your body
because i feel you get it intellectually
yeah but i really want you to drop down
and go
survey says
i've been in multiple depressive states
and i'm here
it hasn't been
dangerous in that i haven't killed
myself if that's what you're calling
danger
yeah that's that would that would be it
yeah so we want you to get that down
especially in the body like your breath
go
ah oh god like really look and feel that
yeah okay
many times depressive states here i am
okay not dangerous yeah
give me another example of how it's true
it's
not dangerous
if i go into a depressive state
uh i'm having trouble honestly i'm
wondering if you can help me brainstorm
here yeah yeah so
i imagine people come around you people
help you
yeah yeah i need to get better at
actually
reaching out but yes when
i do have supportive people around me
and
if i i'm very
lucky to have people who love me who i
would respond at the drop of a dime yeah
so i want you to feel that feel how oh
my goodness i am surrounded by so many
people
and that and experts who could help me
and have in the past so that i couldn't
get myself like you know it was hard to
be dangerous if there's all these other
folks around me who got my back
yeah yeah i believe that for sure and so
i can see it again in your head like
intellectually part of part of what i
want is for you to come back down in the
body
and really feel that because it's a it's
a somatic experience
that i'm wanting you to get
how do you i know this this is like the
the remedial class uh with me but
how do you help people to do that
because it's challenging for me like
like just imagine one of the last times
that you were in one
see all the people who came around you
really there were people there and i
want you to just let your body feel that
like feel oh yeah there were people who
came and asked questions and gave
guidance and offered support and
listened and just let your body go
let your breath open up and feel from
the body the direct experience of
support of non-dangerous that you did
have in the past that wasn't just
intellectual it was a direct experience
of the body
yeah
it's like oh my goodness there was so
much support so much interconnectedness
breathe with that feel that all the way
down through the toes
okay i got it yeah nice yeah thank you
yeah
it's a whole different ballgame when you
include the best that's different yeah
yeah yeah yeah the brain is the the
intellectual side is just like a
glancing blow i mean it's not
it doesn't fully land well yeah and
you're actually not present here to have
the experience of non-dangerous because
if you're not allowing yourself to come
down into the body you're not fully
here
to access
the intelligence that's giving you a
direct experience of not dangerous
right
so you go okay great and then we go okay
so
it's not dangerous is at least as true
we had two examples so far so we're
going to go for one more
and now you might even get more clarity
of how it's not dangerous if you're
listening to your head and your heart
and your body how is it at least is true
that going into a depressive state does
not have to be dangerous
it doesn't have to be i mean sometimes
uh
the episodes are very short i don't know
if that's
i mean that's maybe not as overarching
a line item as the last two that we did
okay let's say it's long because since
long is the one that scares you
so let's say it's a long one how is the
long one not dangerous
i mean this is something i've struggled
with my whole life so i i'm not
i could use i could use an alley-oop
with maybe another i'm just trying it on
myself because i got to go in there i'm
going to try on being depressed and go
in there with you
so i can feel i'm not hurting myself i
can feel i'm surrounded by support
other way it's not dangerous
could be
well what i'm noticing is like there's
an awareness in you that knows you're
depressed right
yeah yeah
so there's a witness who's there
watching
hmm there's a part that's never in
danger who's watching the whole thing
that parts that part's not experiencing
danger
yeah the witness the the witness is
there
yeah so you could go oh when i'm in the
depressive state and i'm
in my witness it's not dangerous for
that one
yeah let me let me sit with that for a
second yeah
yeah it's it's challenging for me i'm
part way there it's like it's partially
landing
since it's also the witness who panics
it's uh well i actually don't think the
witness can't panic if you're in witness
if you're truly in witness the one who's
just a watcher
without a judgment
one it just says like i have a witness
that's like oh check you out diana
you're you're
scaring yourself about being on the tim
ferriss show
you know that was i i literally said
that to myself this morning oh check you
out now my witness is just watching
thinking i'm adorable that i'm scared
and doesn't have an opinion about it
just watches oh there you are
so wonder if you have a relationship
with that part of yourself that just can
watch and observe and
welcome whatever's happening without
judgment
there are times when i do that's that is
a relationship that i want to continue
and
need to continue to cultivate yeah great
but i think that's a good third
sort of third leg of the stool
yeah
so now we go okay we want you to keep
it's dangerous sure it's dangerous to
get in depressive states that that can
be true but it's also at least it's true
that it's not dangerous
and we can see examples of how that's at
least is true so what we're trying to
get the mind to do is to see okay
we'll give you both you could they both
can be true and therefore they're both
not true so then what
then we get to be with what's underneath
all the judgment
there's just what do you notice if you
get to say they're both true they're
both not true then what do you notice
when you imagine that you might
go into a depressive state at some point
well if i'm
able to hold
both of those
equally
then the likelihood of panic
and anxiety about possible panic it's
like panic about panic
right
right uh is is going to be less if i can
hold those two things yeah i call it
walking the line
it's like a walk a line right down the
center where i'm holding both is equally
true
and i value both sides like sure because
i think you know i don't want to be
stupid and i want to dismiss something
and be naive
but i want to be honoring that hey
i'm not right meaning righteous
about this story i have over here
because if i am i'm going to cause
myself some kind of reactivity
so now i just stick with okay depressive
episode may happen and then ideally if i
can walk that line then all i'm going to
do is learn
i'm going to be able to stay present to
what's happening and learn along the way
what needs to happen yeah
my experience is
i have a lot more
trust if i just am willing to welcome
whatever's going to happen
yeah with a preference i have a
preference not to go to a depressive
state for sure but if a depressive state
is what happens okay we'll learn
yeah there's a i don't take us too far
off track but
a friend of mine actually just showed me
a book which has been recommended a
number of times i have not read it so i
can't vouch for it but called feeding
your demons but i at least
like the title
and it's on this this exact
subject yeah because you feed the demon
every time you believe you're right that
it's going to be dangerous you feed the
demon and so then you're just going to
keep amping up the anxiety and then of
course you have that much anxiety over
time you're going to burn out you're
going to get depressed
because the body's going to get
intelligent and go i can't do that i
can't run this anxiety all the time
let's get depressed and just chill out
for a while
yeah
yeah it's um and to connect this also
for people with the
the process so thank you diana for
taking me through that
and
and also
these turnarounds these rephrasings with
the objective of or at least the step of
gathering evidence for each of these
turn rounds could be applied and please
correct me if i'm wrong if we took let's
just say a belief that's causing you
pain is
who knows my sister is selfish right
yeah as a civil war so it could be
my sister is selfish maybe there's
something with your parents and the
sister's not pulling the weight
and you're pissed off and
so your belief is my sister's selfish
could be much worse than that yeah and i
might change it too my sister shouldn't
be selfish
oh yeah that's great that's great right
so my sister shouldn't be selfish
and then you could have you know my
sister should be selfish you could have
i should be selfish i should be selfish
i shouldn't be selfish exactly
and
at the very least i mean in my
experience when i am triggered and i'm
just so disregulated
that
problem solving the idea of problem
solving or coming up with good
strategies is just a joke because i'm so
emotionally disregulated that doing this
type of exercise at the very least just
turns down the volume on the system
reactivity and then
i can just breathe
so i found it very helpful as a pattern
interrupt
yes and to your point this isn't a good
tool to use if you are really
dysregulated at the moment i would
recommend first using breath and
movement to relax the nervous system
to get yourself into more calm first
because if you just try to use this as
your first
thing you might likely use it as a
weapon and just intellectualize it all
and that's not gonna that'll just give
you some temporary relief over and over
again
so i do recommend first getting yourself
use some movement use some breath
calm the nervous system we say
you know handle your blood and brain
chemistry first and then this is a good
tool yeah for me it's just go list go
lift some heavy stuff go to the gym just
stop
i also you know if i were working with
you i'd have you say i
shouldn't have a depressive state i
should have a depressive state and i'd
really go argue for why you should
and do that so that you get it in your
body
not just into your head but i should
have a depressive state again
because that's the other thing i hear is
there's a arguing with it would be bad
or i shouldn't have it or i'm trying to
avoid it instead of
well if it happens it happens
and
it should happen instead of it shouldn't
is at least is true
but that would be a good one to go play
with because i think that would also
help
you be more
open to life happening the way it does
through you
for sure for sure
thank you
uh you know i would like to if you're
open to it shift a little bit to
relationships and
i want to ask you
specifically about your partnership with
with matt so here's
here's one of your superpowers as listed
from
mr jim
creating and sustaining a wonderful
intimate partnership with matt her
husband and lover since they were
teenagers have her talk about the risks
she and they were willing to take to
keep the relationship alive and vital
growing and intimate
if you are game to talk about that i
would be very
interested
yeah
to hear more well
it's a challenge it's it's both a great
gift to be with a partner
since you were young you get to grow up
together there's a lot of a lot of
shared memories and shared friends and
there's a sweetness that it started out
with you get to keep and there's also a
great challenge of
the fact that we are different people
who evolve and change and so uh several
times at least three key times in our
relationship we've been willing to let
it all go
and
we've basically killed it off just said
the relationship as it was is done
now let's just check and see
is there a relationship what is the
relationship that wants to happen moving
forward
maybe it's just friends
co-parents maybe it's lovers
staying married what is it and so
we have a lot of courage both of us to
be willing to let go of what's not
working and trust
that
the right form of the relationship will
reveal itself and it just so happens
that it continues to be us married and
i think you know we we play around often
sometimes we'll get up in the morning
and i'll say something like
hey you want to be married today
and he'll say
oh well
you know like what would that mean what
kind of a husband do i need to be and
we'll giggle and play around with well
you know how about this and this and
then
and then we choose and that is for me
we're
always choosing over and over again and
we always are willing to
to kind of to the point of um using the
work with byron katie of
i'm willing to open to the possibility
that not being married is just as okay
as being married
and what that has created is an
incredibly
vital
creative ever evolving passionate
marriage
in which we're freed up to
keep exploring new ways of of being
together and
i am really proud of my relationship i
think it's one of the greatest things
i've ever done
is the marriage that i have i we get a
lot of feedback that
it's an inspiring marriage to a lot of
people
who
look to it and i do think it comes with
the courage to say no
you mentioned if at least i think you
said three times
that you've had this type of
conversation
i would like to zoom in on the first
conversation
were you both already
prepared and trained to initiate that
type of conversation
did one side initiate the hey let's
decide if we want to
remain as is or if we want to
take one of these other forms i'm just
wondering for people who are listening
who have never had one of these
conversations maybe they've been at the
breaking point but they've never had
this conversation
i initiated it
i initiated it it wasn't matt's
idea i said hey i'm
this isn't working for me the way we're
in relationship and
there's a different kind of a man i want
to be with
than
than
than how you are
and i want something i want to i want
another possibility and so
i was i didn't know how to do all this i
was just toddling around trying to
figure this out
and um
i yeah i said i i don't want to do it
this way anymore and so
i thought that might mean that we needed
to be separated and that we needed to
end the marriage
and i was willing to we actually
got some support from
counselors about telling our kids that
we were going to divorce
because that's the only direction it
seemed like
we were gonna go
and then i had this great advice from a
friend who said okay diana you know i i
love you both if you think divorce is
what needs to happen that's great and
but i hear you complaining that
there's a certain man you want him to be
that he's not
and she said who is the woman you would
need to be to call forward that man
and my stomach dropped and i thought
i don't wanna i don't know about that
what and uh i realized oh i would need
to be a different woman
so
we said let's kill off this old marriage
and let's see if we can create a new one
and i'm going to keep asking myself who
do i need to be to call forward the man
i want to be with
and
about six months later
i was with the man i wanted to be with
and i remember saying to him you really
changed and he said no you really
changed and and the truth is we both
really changed but i was really grateful
for that first conversation of getting
being willing to let it go and then
getting the feedback of hey if you're
the creator
of of who's showing up over there who do
you need to be and
for
many months i felt like i was going to
throw up 24 7 learning to be a much more
vulnerable
needy woman
who called forward the man who
you know could protect and and lead in a
way that i hadn't been willing to be in
the past
how did you thank you for sharing all
this by the way
and very courageous and vulnerable and
how did you figure out
who
you needed to be who who that woman was
to call forth the version
of your husband or the man who you
wanted to be with did you have help
did it was it obvious once you sat with
it
in terms of the changes that needed to
be made on your side or the things you
needed to cultivate or drop how did you
arrive at the answers at first i didn't
know i just knew i was really scared
when i asked the question
and so i i knew that my fear
uh you know i i believe that fear
is when we're present is
an intelligence that says something
needs to get learned
something needs to get learned so when i
had that fear i thought oh wow something
needs to get learned there's i don't
know something here
and so
that was my first clue that her question
was powerful is the fear that arose in
me and i just kept asking the fear
what needs to be learned i just kept
being really broad in that curiosity
i got into a state of wonder i wonder
who i would need to be to call forward
the man i most want to be with
i just kept asking that i wonder and i
let it be okay that i didn't have to
know because i didn't know i've been you
know with him for a long time and i
didn't know so i had to
be willing to listen and learn from
something
greater than my own
my own experience so far
and so it was in that level of curiosity
that i just
found my way
and it was
just baby steps you know a little bit
here a little bit there and
that's happened actually several
different we've had several versions of
that often or not often but the three
versions were all some version of me
something needs to get learned for the
next evolution here
of this relationship
do you have
recommended resources or
practices
that couples
can seek out or
embrace
so that they are better prepared if they
get to these decision points or or just
overall in
with respect to nurturing sort of a
healthy
co-created relationship are there any
any books any
particular
practices that you would highlight for
folks
matt and i studied with gay and katie
hendricks for years at the hendricks
institute they did a lot of relationship
work they still do a bit of it but i
learned so many tools there on
how to get off the drama triangle i
learned about personas and about how
i get caught in these personas that then
unconsciously require the persona of of
my partner to show up in a certain way
that then i can that i complain about
and i learned about how to
how to
unwind those or
shift them when i wanted to
i learned about
the importance of feeling my feelings
i learned about
letting you know really questioning my
stories i learned about polarity and how
important it is to honor polarity that
shows up in couples and making sure that
i honored both sides of the polarity
equally for example a lot of couples
argue about money and almost always
there's one that we call the gas and one
who's the break and somebody who's more
free-flowing with money and somebody
who's more
controlling about money and that's a
can we can we honor these polarities and
can we see the value in both of them
because usually
i was the one who wanted to spend the
money and my husband wanted to control
this you know hold on to the money and
we would get into a battle about you
know you're keeping me from having joy
in my life because you're so stingy
about money and he'd say you're gonna
make us all broke because you're just so
uh you know unconscious about spending
it and so
honoring that those two sides of the
polarity are actually allies
that are here to create just the right
balance
to take care of ourselves and have fun
and so
those are those are all different skill
sets there's so many different tools and
i would say that our book the 15
commitments of conscious leadership we
wrote it for leaders but really it could
be a perfect guidebook for couples if
you just apply
a couple examples in there because
that's what
really created the beautiful
relationship that i have are those
commitments
and those all have tools and skills that
are associated with them
could you give us a few examples of some
of these commitments and of course i i
would recommend people read the book i
think it's it's very valuable
but can you give us
a handful of examples of what these
commitments
are yeah the first
we got a lot of these from gay and katy
hendricks they were the ones they wrote
the first two commitments word for word
and the first two commitments the first
one is all around i commit to take
radical responsibility for the results
in my life
and
that's a cornerstone commitment
and
you know that looks like some guy
who i was coaching the other day called
me up and said my ceo is not giving me
the feedback i need to grow as a leader
and so i had him teach me the class how
do you create the ceo not giving you the
feedback you want he's like what i'm not
creating that he's i'm not the effect of
it he's not giving it to me i said teach
me the class so he
actually thought for a moment and said
well value the ceo's time more than your
time uh don't reschedule when the ceo
breaks your one-on-one meetings
don't ask directly for the feedback you
want and he started to giggle and
realized oh i'm i'm the creator of not
getting the feedback i want that's
radical responsibility
so
people often we say
the thing you're complaining about is
often the thing you're committed to
creating if you can own that that's
radical and then the second commitment
is all around letting go of of one team
to be right and what we mean by that is
the defending yourself righteously that
keeps you from learning and growing
those are the two cornerstone
commitments one and two i think we even
say in the book like you could stop
right here and just practice these for
the rest of your life
but then there's the commitment to
really feel feelings and specifically
what i notice and we talked about this
you and i a little bit when you were
thinking about writing this notebook was
how much we're trying to control each
other feeling feelings so like i don't
want to say no because i don't want you
to have a feeling over there and i
really think i'm right you shouldn't
have them and i don't want you to have a
feeling because then maybe i'll have a
feeling and i see how much of our drama
in the workplace and at home is coming
from suppressing feelings in ourselves
and each other
candor is a commitment to be able to
say what's going on rather than
conceal it which then causes me to have
to start to withdraw
and uh ending gossip
is another commitment
really being impeccable around
agreements so that i do what i say i'm
going to do it's another commitment
those first six really that's what we
focus a lot in the business world when
we come and work with teams we have them
work on those six commitments
to help secure the identity and relax
drama and then once that's done then we
have things like let's look at
appreciation the commitment to
appreciate
the commitment to play and rest the
commitment to live in our zones of
genius
and then the commitments get even deeper
into
being the source of approval control and
security rather than trying to source it
outside of yourself which is probably
one of the most difficult commitments of
all
and also the commitment of experiencing
that you already have enough which most
people also struggle with especially at
least in the business world i rarely
ever come across anybody who has enough
time
and then and then they go on from there
to being able to create a win for all
solution which is one of my
just one of my great joys to
work with a team where there's a lot of
different needs and it seems like they
can't come up with a solution where they
all win and helping them do that
and
finally be the resolution to that which
you see missing in the world so if
they're not listening be a better
listener
if they're not taking care of things
take care of things
do you still
use
or recommend people use mind
jogger
i read that at least for a period of
time you used
an app i believe it was mind jogger that
would ask you multiple times a day diana
in this now moment are you above
the line or below the line
i still use it i use it every day
and
i ask that basic question where are you
are you above the line meaning are you
in a state of trust or are you below the
line in a state of threat so i ask that
i have it seven times randomly per day
it pops on my screen and i pause and
look and check
that's
uh just like it's like for me it's like
lifting weights every day
so that's one and then i use other
questions that i rotate around like one
i'm really liking right now is
is this exquisite
diana is this
moment exquisite and then
it gives me a pause to think about how
could this be more exquisite
what does that mean to you
exquisite is whole body yes to me you
know is this a whole body yes is this ah
is this
yes i'm in my zone i feel fully alive
i'm
i'm doing what i most want to be doing
i'm on purpose
what other what other prompts do you
have or do any others come to mind oh
yeah i mean i go i have a question for
each of the commitments so i rotate them
around like what are you feeling right
now so if i need to keep checking with
my feeling states
another one would be what do you
appreciate about somebody around you
right now and then i'll use that as an
opportunity to speak that out loud
because i'm really a big fan of lots and
lots of appreciation
another one do i have enough time right
now i use that one are you experiencing
enough time right now is a way to pause
and go oh good that's i'm so glad i
asked myself that question because i can
feel i'm in a scarcity of time and let
me stop and pause
and get back into the present moment
where there's always enough
if you could email those those questions
prompts that you have for each
commitment but i would love to i just
downloaded mindjogger this morning i
would love to start playing with those
if you're open to it oh yeah
absolutely yeah maybe we could put them
in the show notes as well and that way
people can can find them for themselves
i have to say you know i
i really think you are a master of
prompts and questions and we we don't
have to
go through it at length i was actually
going to read every single bullet i'm
not going to do that because it'll take
a bit of time but you have a piece on
linkedin it's an article called how to
assess self-awareness in a hiring
interview now people might hear that and
say why the hell are you bringing that
up it sounds so niche it sounds so
specific it's only going to apply to
three percent of your listenership but
it's a great example of
questions and prompts
for
uncommon insight i really just i i was i
was very impressed
with the questions i'll give just a few
examples describe a time when you were
tempted to blame someone else for
something but instead resolved it by
owning part of the issue right what
percentage of agreements do you
currently keep with the people you live
and work with what causes you to break
agreements the most
how do you approach broken agreements i
mean these are outstanding
questions
not just by the way for hiring people
[Laughter]
but i found these these questions and
prompts to be outstanding so i will also
link to those in the show notes
and people will be able to find
find that article well my clients were
asking me hey how do we interview if we
want people who
want to come and be in a part of a
culture that doesn't have as much drama
what should we be asking
that would make sure that we knew they
were good fit for the culture we're
creating here and so that was what
caused me to put those questions
together
and
i use them myself you know we were just
we just did a couple of big hires at the
conscious leadership group and we almost
exclusively focused on self-awareness
and
people's ability to
have candor
take responsibility keep their
agreements as the one of the primary
things we were looking at because you
know they were already very successful
candidates so we knew they were they had
a great pedigree already so we wanted to
make sure they were a good culture fit
because we're really committed to no no
or very little drama in our workplace
diana
uh we could go for hours and hours and
hours we might just have to do a round
two sometime i'd love to
it's because i'm curious quite frankly
to know
what books outside of the 15 commitments
of conscious leadership have you gifted
the most to other people
or gifted a lot doesn't have to be the
most but what book what books have you
gifted a fair amount to people the big
leap by gay hendricks is probably the
book i've
gifted the most
and the one i've recommended the most of
any other book
and
also i conscious loving for couples
because you asked that question earlier
conscious loving i think is a fantastic
book for couples who are wanting to
get more um connected
is another one i've gifted a lot
and um
yeah
those are the those are the two that
come top of mind the two primaries for
people who just want to preview
what is the big leap about or what is it
for the big leap is all about learning
to live in your zone of genius which i
think is just the most fun thing
and to take a look at what are the
things that keep us from living in our
zone of genius and so
i um
i tell every leader i coach to get it
and it's 100 of them have said it was a
valuable read
and gays just come up with a follow-up
book on zone of genius that just came
out last month that i imagine will be
another book i'll be recommending and
gifting
because i find that
inside of all of us is
some creativity that
like when we are in that place time and
space go away it's so
fun
and makes life so worth living and i
really am excited about supporting
people and living as much as possible in
that zone of genius
well i think you do
hey a damn fine job of it it's been fun
to get to know you it's been fun to also
get to know you in this chat a bit more
and doing homework it's always fun to do
research on friends which would
otherwise be super creepy in like google
stocking but
i have a pretext and excuse which is
doing interviews
and people can find the conscious
leadership group at conscious dot i s
and certainly all the social and so on
can be found from that jumping off point
you also have a lot of pdfs and
resources
for people on the website so i encourage
people to check out their website we'll
link to that we'll link to
prompts we'll link to everything that we
discussed in the show notes at tim.blog
podcast
diane is there anything else that you
would like to say or ask any request of
the audience anything at all that you'd
like to
add before we come to a close
that's a great question let me see i
want to sit with that because i think
that's
i think um
i feel
i feel pretty heartbroken these days
about um
the drama that is happening amongst us
and i'm actually grateful for the
heartbreak because it's helping me
connect more with
um
with love
and
one of the things i'm doing is facing
i'm really facing the cost of the drama
that we're having
and so i think one of the things i most
hope people will do is have the courage
to face
the cost of the drama that we are
creating
in our workplaces that has people so
overwhelmed at work
the cost politically
environmentally
and that they're willing to face it feel
that let their
hearts break wide open and then from
that place get curious and excited about
what else could we create together
what else is possible because that
really excites me and i think
that i'm not i don't want to argue with
the way the world is it's just fine the
way it is
and i have a preference for a lot more
play and creativity
and togetherness and curiosity that um
that i find when we drop the drama
that is an excellent place
to close and what
what a
enjoyable and i think very helpful for
me conversation so thank you very much
diana for
for making the time and being so present
thank you uh my my great pleasure i'm
i'm
so grateful for all the ways you go out
into the world and
bring forward um
things that help people live more
connected and valuable lives and
it is one of the things that i believe
your depression has been a great gift is
i don't know that you would have done
this if you hadn't had the depressions
that you had and needed to find the
tools that you needed
so i'm grateful for your depression
and
for your own unique journey that has now
enhanced so many of ours so so thank you
so much
oh thank you so much diana i really
appreciate it thank you and
for everybody listening
stay strong get curious check out the
show notes at tim dot blog forward slash
podcast
and until next time thank you for tuning
in
you